a cheating mother a mysterious lover and
a snake charmer like no other all that
and so much more on Sweetwater secrets
[Music]
welcome back river babes I'm Liana
Galera your honorary pussycat host and
this is the Sweetwater Secrets
after-show for episode 207 chapter 20
tales from the dark side which featured
three mini stories including one on my
girl Josie finally alright guys you know
the drill there are massive spoilers
ahead as well as behind-the-scenes
secrets from stars Ashley Marie and
Madeline Peck about this episode's most
mind-blowing moment so you've been
warned because according to pop tape the
reckoning is upon us now let's jump
right into the top headlines of the week
and this week's blue-and-gold
breakdown alright guys first up
detective Betty is on the case again and
this time she has her killer sights set
on sheriff Keller but it appeared to
lead to a dead end
now Kevin's dad may not be the black
hood but we do know that he is seriously
in shape rich Andrews watch your back
oh and that he's stepping out on his
wife with the also married mayor McCoy
uh-oh
better watch herself lovers because we
all know that the black hood hunts down
adulterers it's obvious next up the
snake charmers fangs are filled with
lies
thanks to Penny Peabody's deceptively
vicious blackmailing ways Archie and
Jughead took a spooky yet romantic
journey to Greendale
they made a delivery to a really bizarre
new character and although we never
discovered what was in the crate
something tells me that it wasn't
pancakemix and it looks like this is
only the beginning of jugheads
delivery-boy career FP made me a promise
that he didn't keep as far as I'm
concerned his debt is yours and I am
just getting started with you
side note what do you guys think F Peas
promise was now I personally think he
promised to marry penny but then broke
things off but that's just my theory hit
the comments with your own moving on to
seven seconds in heaven alright guys now
this adorable bug head moment had me
swooning but I'm so confused
alright now Betty isn't jugheads bed
wearing Jughead shirt so did they sleep
together or sleep together now if they
did it then I'm pissed that we missed
out on that milestone moment and if they
didn't then I'm curious to know how
Betty managed to secure a sleepover with
her serpent Bay because you know the
Alice Cooper would not let that fly but
the biggest romance shocker of the week
is the fact that Josie started receiving
love notes and intensive gifts from a
secret admirer who could this mystery
baby now although Josie first suspected
Chuck Clayton and my money was on the
creepy janitor it was actually revealed
to be dun dun dun Cheryl this town is
seriously oh are you confused yeah me
too
so here's what Madeleine Pech had to
tell me about why Cheryl is so drawn to
Josie pun totally intended we're gonna
be getting to know a little bit more
about their friendship and their
backstory what can you tease about that
um
we always talk about it I know a lot in
last season we talked about how close
they were but you never really saw it on
camera but Josie is the only real ally
Cheryl has in the school of all the
person that Cheryl is willing to open up
to Ethan the littlest but she's only
opened up to her too much but they
create a really beautiful friendship in
the beginning of the season and then
chaos
I'm loving the fact that Cheryl's
getting the love interest this year as a
mine she needs love I think of the first
season I always said in interviews that
it was nice that she was an independent
woman and she was figuring herself out
that phase has passed I think she's kind
of she's still obviously figuring
herself out a little bit but she's
discovered that she has no love no
homebase no friends and this season her
undercurrent is absolutely love she
really wants to be loved and she's
looking for it and all the right and all
the wrong places
hmm all right guys now what do you think
about Cheryl's new obsession with Josie
and I recall them Josie Gerald hit the
comments and tell me but now let's sink
our claws into this week's this is an
kisses all right guys this is - sheriff
Keller's cheating ways and - Chuck
Clayton's nice guy act keep in mind that
in Riverdale time it's only been a few
weeks since he started that horrible
rumor about Veronica so sorry Chuck I'm
not buying it
that's fine this is penny Peabody's
blackmailing ways and for lying about
our precious FP being hurt no hisses -
the fact that Jughead and Betty clearly
still had not had the Tony topes talk
now don't get me wrong on all four bug
head cuddles but I think it's only a
matter of time before the truth comes
out and we hear those five little iconic
words we were on the bridge and my last
hiss goes to the fact that the Pussycats
are fighting you know I bet Sheryl was
the one who tipped off the girls -
Josie's future solo career but here's
what Ashley Marie had to say about the
Pussycats continued drama there's gonna
be a bit of boat rocking in season two
with the Pussycats and that has more to
do with Josie than it does the other
girls and they are rightfully upset
about it I hope to see some
reconciliation like between the three of
them I don't know if it's gonna happen
you know we'll see how it plays out but
it's it's gonna be a bit of a tough ride
this year all right guys well moving on
to kisses that one is going straight to
us getting to know Kevin a little bit
more and learning that he's a little bit
of a low-key dork glass of milk would be
great and now I just love him even more
kisses - another B&V team-up
- Josie gracing us
with her voice and then you smile and
Archie's dream of the core for moving to
New York because it's the Riverdale and
Gossip Girl mashup of my dreams it's me
I'm Gossip Girl alright vixens now that
does it for my rants on this week's
after-show for episode 207 and now I
want to hear from you hit the comments
below or chat with me on Twitter about
your top hisses and kisses of the week
plus I want to hear your theories on fps
broken promise to Penny and if you're
happy or horrified for Cheryl's fierce
new affections for Josie this sick game
you're playing with my girl ends now now
please give this video a like subscribe
to EJ's YouTube channel share this with
your friends and ring the bow so you
never miss an episode of Sweetwater
Secrets adore you lots River babes and
I'll catch you next time
[Music]
you